consequently the logical flaw in that
is that if you can't say that anyone's
lifestyle
or culture is better than anyone else's
then you can't say that liberalism is
better than anyone else's
and consequently you can't defend the
fundamental liberal values of
freedom of speech and tolerance of other
points of view
and freedom of religion all those all
those things which make a liberal
tolerant society
you can't defend them you can't defend
the equality of women
so when faced with say the islamic world
as a liberal today you cannot say that
the west is
better than the islamic world even
though it is
because surely the enslavement of women
must be worse than freedom for women
first off what do you think is wrong and
i hate to say this as someone that still
considers myself a liberal in that
true sense do you think there is an
inherent flaw in liberalism
that has allowed leftism and
collectivism
to basically decimate it so that there
are very few people
at this point in the west certainly in
america who describe themselves as
liberals the way we're talking about it
most of these
anyone listening to this right now would
say oh they sound
mostly like conservatives i probably
come up
come off a little more on the
libertarian side of that um
but do you think there is an actual flaw
in in the good sense of liberalism that
allowed
this this monster in
perhaps a protection that that
conservatism has
that liberalism doesn't have well
the fundamental flaw in liberalism
um uh in the way that it's been
developed is that it i mean let's put it
in this way there's there are different
types of liberalism
there's the liberalism which comes out
of um
i would say conservatism or other
conservatism
is a kind of defense of liberalism if
you look at the one of the greatest
uh philosophers of what's called
conservatism
edmund burke um in the 18th century
uh now he's called a conservative but
what he reacted against was the french
revolutionary terror
he understood that the french revolution
which was supposedly
all about freeing the individual and
uh introducing the rule of reason
divorced from religion a whole lot of
other stuff but that's broadly what it's
about
yeah it led directly to terror so he
reacted against that
and as a result he was called a
conservative and he's still called a
conservative
he's called one of the fathers of
conservatism but from where i'm standing
he was actually defending liberalism he
was different
so what was he defending he was
defending tolerance and freedom
and progress and reason these are all
things which i associate with liberalism
now liberalism has a fundamental flaw
it is that it uh it has two fundamental
flaws
uh one is that uh it um
because it prioritizes the individual um
it has been interpreted over time in our
in our current time to mean that
you can't then uh establish
any kind of hierarchy of values you
can't say that one set of values is
better than anyone else's because that's
kind of being nasty to somebody else
and consequently the logical flaw in
that
is that if you can't say that anyone's
lifestyle
or culture is better than anyone else's
then you can't say that liberalism
is better than anyone else's and
consequently you can't defend
the fundamental liberal values of
freedom of speech
and tolerance of other points of view
and freedom of religion and all those
all those things which make a liberal
tolerant society
you can't defend them you can't defend
the equality of women
so when faced with say the islamic world
as a liberal today you cannot say that
the west is
better than the islamic world even
though it is
because surely the enslavement of women
must be worse than freedom for women and
equality for women
so that is one of the essential i think
contradictions in liberalism that means
that it's it's sort of
going down the plug plus the fact that
um
[Music]
it's an it's an it's become um a
libertarian ideology that is to say
it's taken the the notion of the dignity
of the individual and respect for the
individual which
in my view is at the heart of liberalism
um
but uh in my view that can only be
enshrined by
paradoxically a body of laws and moral
values that are regarded
as kind of binding on you but if you
uh detach the individual from those laws
then you get a kind of free-for-all um
and once you have a free-for-all
then it's everyone out from him or
herself
and then you have the the strong
dominating the weak and then you get to
a situation
very fast which is where we've got to
where you don't have a liberal society
you have a tremendously illiberal
society
and that's made even worse by the fact
that this kind of liberalism or i would
call it
libertarianism is actually an
ideology now what's an ideology an
ideology is where
the power of the idea must
trounce everything else you can't
ever say the idea is wrong so if you
come along with a load of facts and you
say
well this idea is wrong because here are
the facts
here is the evidence that shows it's
wrong well the ideology says
you must be wrong there can be no
challenge to the ideology
and so you have to be stopped you have
to be suppressed
because the ideology of liberalism is
that it's bound up with the betterment
of humanity the perfection of the world
so anyone who stands against that isn't
just wrong
they're actually evil and if they're
evil
they have to be stopped and so you have
this phenomenon
in which we have people who purport to
be liberal
who are stamping out free expression
on our campuses preventing people from
speaking
which is absolutely the absolute
antithesis
of true liberal values and that's the
paradox of liberalism it's become an
illiberal ideology melanie you
would absolutely love my book so i'm
going to get your address after and send
it to you because i'm i'm making many of
the
the same arguments and that that
connection between
between truly being liberal and having
something outside of yourself which i
think we're gonna we're gonna get to
in a little bit but i want to back up
for a second because you said that you
grew up in a secular jewish household
that was similar to most of the others
in the 50s can you sort of describe what
does that mean
and and one of the questions i get all
the time now is
what happened to the jews how did the
jews all become lefties when the left
has become so rabidly
anti-jewish anti-israel anti-liberal
all of those things i mean i think you
can probably trace a pretty clean thread
on that but can you first describe what
did it mean to grow up in
a secular jewish household because i
think that confuses some people
and then and then sort of the road that
that takes us on yeah
well to make people even more confused
it wasn't what i would call strictly
speaking a secular household i mean
certainly uh
highly orthodox observant people might
well call it that but
i didn't think of it like that my
parents belonged to an orthodox
synagogue
they went to synagogue three times a
year the two days of rosh hashanah
and yom kippur we did not observe the
shabbat
in that my parents worked they were
modest people
and they had to work or they felt they
had to work
but we were kosher uh really kosher at
home
and out and um
we had a friday night meal with candles
and
kiddush and you know i didn't go out
but we had the television on it was that
kind of upbringing
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell